is a look at the lifestrange remastered
collection
feels so weird to be back after five
years or still max caulfield
what do you remember about us as kids
i think about us as little pirates
running and jumping through arcadia bay
we are awesome
come on let's dance or take my picture
with your new camera
we both got scars that's rachel amber
after my dad died and you moved i felt
abandoned
oh good you're here rachel saved my life
she was my angel something happened to
her
we have to find her max
i discovered i could reverse time
what the hell is this
[Music]
whatever's going on between us is
special step back before you regret it
then i realized i had a choice and the
power to change
everything our candy bay is on the edge
of disaster
time to change time whatever happens
i'll always have your back always
hi i'm maya also known as mxm tune
i'm a musician and the singing voice of
alex chen
in the upcoming life is strange true
colors
i hope you enjoyed that first look at
official gameplay from the remastered
collection
as a longtime fan i know i did you can
see the love
and care that dec nine have put into
remastering both life is strange
and before the storm this collection
features improved character animation
lip sync and visuals breathing new life
into these two beloved games
back in march we also revealed the next
major game in the series
life is strange true colors a small town
supernatural mystery
alex chen must uncover the truth behind
her brother's death using her psychic
power of empathy to unravel the shocking
secrets of haven springs
today we have a first look at alex's
unique power in action
here's game director zach garris for
more
alex's psychic power of empathy is
integral to the story of life's strange
true colors
it impacts every relationship she builds
and every decision she makes
never thought i'd have a freaky and bad
friend
for years alex has been unable to shut
out the strong feelings of others
the fear sadness and anger of those
around her
leading her to believe her power is a
curse
in the wake of gabe's death alex
realizes the only way she can find the
truth
is to embrace her power i can't believe
this is happening
and the only way to understand is to
feel what he's feeling
from the very start you can use alex's
power to focus on brightly colored auras
to gain an insight into people's
emotions
these valuable insights deepen alex's
relationships with the folk of haven
springs
as well as sparking new dialogue options
and events
as here from a scene very early on in
the game
you're gonna lose her you're gonna lose
her and it's all
your fault alex has uncovered a secret
that mack wants to keep hidden from his
long-term girlfriend
and now he is terrified that alex will
reveal it before he can talk to
riley she is the best thing that's ever
happened to me
so please help me out
max telling you a whole lot of [ __ ]
thanks for telling me the truth alex
are we still together are you serious
i need to get back to work sure alex
will uh
we'll get out of your way
when alex encounters a particularly
strong aura she can reach out to
actively connect with that person's
emotions
this generates a nova a supernatural
flair that transforms the world around
alex into a reflection of that person's
psyche
in this altered emotionally charged
state alex can experience fragments of
thoughts and memories
to get to the root of their issue
but not every emotional crisis can be
easily dealt with
some carry a dangerous even
life-threatening amount of power
he's dead i wish i were too
no decision is easy and the consequences
will be felt across the game
this anger could kill her what if
i could just take it away
using alex's powers the only way you can
uncover the truth behind her brother's
death
what would that do to her what would it
do to me
and even if i can
should i how far will you go in pursuit
of that truth
the choice is yours
alex's powers look so awesome
i have no idea how i'll make some of
these choices but i can't wait to play
it with you all when it comes out on
september 10th don't forget
you can pre-order life is strange true
colors now
and if you choose the ultimate edition
you'll also receive the life estranged
remastered collection
and that's it for today make sure to
follow the life is strange social
channels
for more
you